Hey Youtubers it’s Charlie and since Arrow
is on break this week I’m doing some bonus
predictions for the rest of the season.
Based on the episode descriptions and behind
the scenes pictures here are at least five
big questions that I’m going to ask and
try to answer in this video.
I’m going to leave a lot of the Season 3
talk for a future video.
So this will just be stuff happening in the
rest of season 2.
If you’re finding me for the first time
Wednesday and Thursday are kind of unofficially
DC days.
Whenever there’s new episodes I also do
bonus Q&As be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Next week is a really cool Flash Crossover.
So here are my top 5 questions for the rest
of the season, I’m going to answer these,
but please write your own opinions in the
comments as we go down the list, number 5
- What is Slade going to do with the Super
Soldier Army?
Not just this season, but what’s he intending
to do with them once their done?
I think the Army is just a means to an end.
The end of Oliver that is.
Slade is trying to tear down Oliver’s life,
and of all the relationships in his life,
his Family and his friends, one of the biggest
is Starling City itself.
Slade could have just killed Oliver by himself,
he didn’t need Brother Blood or Ravager,
who I’m just calling Summer Glau now.
Because he’s all about making Oliver suffer,
he needs to make the city suffer.
So he’s just going to blow up a big part
of the city and kill a lot of people.
Basically turn the city into something you’d
see in Grand Theft Auto.
If he’s successful, what’s he planning
on doing with them after?
I don’t think he’s going to use them like
a new League of Assassins, he’s not building
an evil organization.
So I think he intends to just walk away when
it’s all done.
He’s a loner, we saw in Episode 18 that
he doesn’t even really care about Brother
Blood.
So he’s just going to disappear again when
it’s all done.
There’s also the chance that he’ll destroy
all the new super soldiers himself.
They’re convicts, so the arrangement he
made with them, seems very temporary.
Like he doesn’t really care if they survive
after his business with Oliver is over.
Number 4 - What is Laurel going to do now
that she knows Oliver is the Arrow?
The producers made this really offhanded comment
that audiences are expecting her to freak
out, but we’ll be surprised when we see
her actual response.
I think that just means that Laurel will be
down with it.
She saw a little action during Birds of Prey
and in the description for episode 21 City
of Blood it says that she’s on the hunt
for Sebastian again.
Ever since they started showing her with him
way earlier this season I’ve thought she
might end up being the one to take him down.
It’s like you have Oliver versus Slade and
over on the side, you have Laurel taking on
Brother Blood.
Now that we know Ravager is a villain I wonder
if Sara will take her on directly or if they’ll
let Felicity do the honors.
There’s all this Laurel Black Canary talk
in the periphery, I still think it’s way
too early for her to become Black Canary.
I’m still crossing my fingers that Sara
will survive to next season.
Which brings me to Number 3 - Who Is Going
To Die?
We also should ask, is anyone going to die.
I think so, I just feel like the show has
been escalating things so much, eventually
the only way to top it all will be to kill
a major character.
It could totally be a supporting character
like Moira or Merlyn, but think about it this
way.
Any Characters that are either currently or
will become superheroes are probably safe.
But reportedly there was a bunch of extras
on set for episode 21 for a funeral scene.
No word on who the funeral was for, but I
think that we can consider said funeral to
come after a big character death.
Side note though, I will be super bummed if
it all turns out to be misdirection.
Like it’s a funeral for a character we didn’t
really see a lot.
Here’s something else that’s really important
and hopefully it will make you feel better.
Caity Lotz was listed on the call sheet for
episode 22 Streets of Fire.
So Sara will still be alive then.
Meaning she’s not going to die.
I actually cheered a little when I saw this.
So I think she’s going to survive to season
3.
Meaning Laurel won’t become Black Canary
yet.
It also means they can do more Birds of Prey
next season.
Amanda Waller has to recruit Huntress at some
point.
on to Number 2 - Will Ivo Turn Out To be Felicity’s
Father?
We still haven’t seen the rest of what happened
on the Island before Oliver took Slade’s
eye out.
Ivo is also still alive.
There are so many things that line up with
what Felicity has said about her father and
what Ivo has said about himself in all the
Island scenes.
Andrew Kriesberg said that we would learn
more about Felicity’s backstory in the next
couple of episodes, but they’re holding
a bunch of stuff till season 3.
The only reason they’d do that is if it’s
something really important.
So even if her father isn’t Ivo, he’s
someone very important in the DC Universe.
That doesn’t mean he’s evil, but it does
mean the show isn’t going to tell us outright
who he is.
For now, let’s just stick with Ivo until
we get more details.
and my Number 1 Question - How is Oliver going
to defeat Slade?
We’ve got the description for episode 21
and that’s it.
Oliver tries to just flat out surrender to
Slade but it sounds like Team Arrow locks
him up so he can’t.
I also don’t think Slade would stop his
plans just because Oliver surrendered.
So there are a couple possible solutions.
Oliver could find a way to overpower Slade
and mortally wound him.
He’s almost invincible, Slade talking about
how the Mirakuru healed his body proves Oliver
isn’t going to be able to kill him without
chopping his head off.
Which I don’t think he’s going to do.
He’s not a killer, that’s the whole arc
of this season.
He’s not killing people anymore.
So that opens the door on a bigger threat
coming along like Ra’s Al Ghul.
Something that would force Slade to stop attacking
Oliver for a minute and make him redirect
his evil energy to the League of Assassins.
Manu Bennett kind of teased this, but the
producers said that some special things might
end up happening in the finale.
But they completely depended on a bunch of
stuff working out.
I think they were just talking about wanting
to do Ra’s Al Ghul and Warner Brothers just
had to agree to let them use the character.
It took a long time for them to get permission
to do Barry Allen and The Flash, so hopefully
it all worked out and we’ll see Ra’s.
That would mean Slade and Oliver could temporarily
cease fire and be brothers again so to speak,
while they try to fend of the League.
That doesn’t really address the issue of
Evil Tinkerbell Shado.
I don’t think Oliver will take the Mirakuru
out of Slade’s body, but I do think Team
Arrow will find a way to get rid of evil Shado.
I don’t think they’ll kill off Slade,
they didn’t even kill Merlyn.
They’re just to awesome to completely get
rid of.
Plus John Barrowman was on set for the finale.
So Merlyn will play a role in whatever the
final outcome is.
Now it’s your turn though, how do you think
they’ll fix Slade and do you think Moira
is going to die?
Or someone else?
I’m not doing a Q&A this week, so I’ll
just be answering questions in the comments.
Next week is the Flash Crossover though.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
In the meantime learn more about the new Team
Deathstroke here.
And click here to learn more about Captain
America 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!